the omicron coronavirus variant is
spreading rapidly around the world case
numbers have exploded in many countries
in the united states omicron is now the
dominant strain accounting for 73 of all
infections just a week ago the figure
was 12 percent in new york city virus
cases are surging just ahead of holiday
season gatherings
five four
three
two one happy new year
this is just a test new year's eve in
times square has not come early but the
omicron wave has hit the u.s sooner than
many experts expected
nearby new yorkers line up to get tested
with christmas just days away and cases
surging many are worried
it definitely feels like that first wave
of the pandemic with that anxiety all
these long lines around the city people
getting tested
exams are getting cancelled for people
in grad school like myself so it kind of
feels like that early part of the
pandemic where we didn't really know
what was happening i think we've all
been affected as a new yorker we're
trying to take every single precaution
that we can
got double vac boosted regular testing i
am planning to travel for the holidays
but depending on the result of this test
i'll probably stay put in new york
america's top pandemic advisor anthony
fauci though had a hopeful message for
those worried about the holidays you can
go the extra mile
and get tested before you have a family
gathering or a group
get tested the day before or the day of
getting together
but vaccinated and boosted people one of
the family members of vaccinated should
feel very comfortable
in getting together and enjoying a
holiday meal or a holiday get-together
president joe biden plans to address the
rapid rise in coronavirus cases later on
tuesday but he's already made it clear
where some of the blame lies for those
who choose to remain unvaccinated he'll
issue a stark warning and make clear
unvaccinated individuals will continue
to drive hospitalizations and deaths
that is not trying to scare people or
maybe it is trying to make clear to
people in the country what the risks are
here of not being vaccinated
despite the worsening situation in times
square some people were still in a
festive mood
but this might be the last time new
yorkers see these lights in person the
mayor still hasn't decided if new year's
celebrations here will go ahead
let's get more from peter chin hong he's
a professor of medicine at the
university of california in san
francisco good to have you back with us
uh tell us dr hinchong a week ago
omicron accounted for just 12 percent of
u.s infections now it's 73
what does that tell you about the virus
it tells us terry that this virus is
speeding ahead and forward like no other
variant before and if you think about
two weeks ago it was one percent so it
tells us really two things first of all
that probably genomic sequencing lags uh
what the cases really are in the
community and secondly once you get
enough people infected in a community
it's like little coronavirus bombs going
off the uh increase is really
exponential
coronavirus bombs what do you expect the
situation to be like then two weeks from
now in the u.s
well i see continued spread i think it
started off in the east coast really
because of a lot of contact with the uk
and with the southern african countries
there are direct flights from
johannesburg for example
to new york new jersey dc
it's not as prevalent maybe in
california yet although it's increasing
our hospitalizations are not that high
compared to the east coast but it's
spreading westward so i see a big sweep
i see it uh potentially unprepared
hospital systems for this deluge
texas has reported what's believed to be
the first known omicron related death in
the u.s uh do we know yet whether
omicron is more deadly than other
variants
we don't know that for sure terry but in
many cases this first death that's
confirmed to omnicron in u.s is a
metaphor of what's to come this was an
unvaccinated individual who was
previously exposed naturally but because
of unvaccinated and unboosted it kind of
confirmed our predict greatest
prediction and fears uh very seriously
ill death uh if not vaccinated he got
regeneron and these monoclonal
antibodies are no good against omnicron
these particular types we need
others that are less available in the us
for them to work
how well is the us prepared for what's
coming
well i think we're not as prepared as we
should be i think this took the biden
administration by surprise it came out
of left field almost
and i think that uh in all senses
testing has been seriously uh
under under-provided um a hospital
capacities are breaking points
regionally uh national guard is being
called out but i think probably the
greatest potential casually is not the
physical beds it's the you know
psychological state of american people
at this point we wanted to have a
christmas where we can go to theater and
see friends and family and all of a
sudden this is that greatest threat
professor thank you very much for
talking with us that was dr peter chin
hong talking to us from san francisco
thanks so much terry
now the world health organization is
calling on people to cancel some of
their holiday plans to help contain the
rapid spread of the omicron variant wh
director general tedros gabriella said
there is now clear evidence that omicron
is more contagious than any other
version of the virus so far and he
warned that holiday festivities would in
many places lead to increased cases and
more deaths
all of us are
sick of this pandemic
all of us want to spend time with
friends and family
but an event council is better
than a life cancelled
it's better to cancel now and celebrate
later
than to celebrate now and grieve later
let's take a look at some other
developments in the pandemic new zealand
has postponed opening its borders amid
concerns over the omicron variant
quarantine free travel is now possible
for new zealanders only from the end of
february onwards in australia infection
rates have surged with the state of news
of south wales reporting 3 000 new cases
on tuesday alone but the australian
government has been reluctant to impose
new restrictions
european union meanwhile has approved
the use of the novovax vaccine in people
aged 18 and older european medicine
agencies said data shows the vaccine has
an efficacy of around 90 percent
well germany's leaders are meeting today
to plot this country's response to the
omicron variant new cases have eased off
recently but experts are warning the
next wave of infections could be the
biggest yet
new coronavirus infections in germany
rose in the autumn peaking at over 70
000 per day in late november and have
since dipped to around 50 000 in recent
days
well here's a look at infection rates in
other countries where omicron is now
dominant the uk has hit its highest
numbers ever with 800 people per 100 000
infected over the last seven days the
weekly rate in denmark has risen even
higher
to more than a thousand the netherlands
is below 600. germany's infection rate
is just over 300 but as we said that is
expected to rise quickly
a range of measures are on the table in
germany including limiting social
contacts even for those who are doubly
vaccinated or recovered from covet 19.
preparing for omicron germany is rushing
to get a vaccine booster shot to its
critical workers like these firefighters
in hamburg before the new covet 19
variant becomes dominant here
while daily cases are sinking across the
country experts warn the dreaded wave
could arrive just after christmas
exponentially it's a rapid exponential
increase
if you take the conservative estimate
that cases double every three days or
what scientists in britain are reporting
every two days
you only need a pocket calculator to see
that that's extremely fast
while vaccines are the first line of
defense germany's government is
preparing new restrictions for as early
as next week
even for the fully vaccinated
we will have further restrictions on
private contacts so we're well prepared
for the spread of the new virus mutation
all over europe
what the new curbs will look like is
unclear that still needs to be discussed
with the leaders of germany states but
it seems everything is on the table
if experts predictions are confirmed and
what we're seeing in neighboring
countries continues then we can't rule
out a general lockdown including
everything from businesses to education
to private gatherings
for starters that will likely mean
cancelled new year's eve parties and
those making fitness resolutions for
2022 might have to postpone hitting the
gym until the omicron wave is over
well for more on on the crown let's talk
now to hayao zeeb he's a research fellow
at the leibniz institute for prevention
research and epidemiology thanks for
being with us professor z when are you
expecting omicron to become dominant in
germany
uh good morning we are a little bit
behind i guess but it won't take that
long i mean it probably will be sometime
early or late as mid-january that will
have omicron really as a dominant
variant with us here
are the restrictions that germany has in
place now sufficient to deal with this
new variant
well let's say the current restrictions
that we have right now are actually
geared towards the delta variants still
so i mean we are looking now towards the
new restrictions coming up this the
discussions today are going on and
the the ministers will sit together and
decide one or more of of that
probably
round about or directly after christmas
that the expectation that especially you
know meeting people and contacts will be
uh will be severely reduced probably the
larger meetings larger gatherings will
probably be
the rules will be changed again and i'm
wondering whether you know restaurants
and all that will possibly close again
here
what are your biggest concerns about
omicron when it does become the dominant
uh variant here in germany
yeah i mean we heard it's spreading very
fast it will lead to a wave of of new uh
diseases definitely and it will end up
in the hospitals that's the one
that's the one problem so we already
have a stressed infrastructure just
about you know coping with delta
as it is but
there will be more of that and even
probably bigger numbers in the hospitals
but then there's also another discussion
about you know that this uh it's just
the the the omicron infection will
really affect uh you know critical
services uh be it you know firefighters
and police and all that so this is
really something new we haven't
discussed this so far and this is
another
threat that's up on the agenda really
now
what about the hospitals the health care
system in germany is it prepared for
this
yeah it's it's it's really a problematic
situation we have a
good hospital system we have uh yeah
enough
icu uh interest infrastructure but it's
it's been stressed severe you know
through the delta variant we had to
transport you know patients from one
place to the other and so on and this is
only delta so now whether omicron
will even stress this this more and and
really especially the staff in the
hospitals then that's the main issue we
have beds but the staff is simply you
know very much under pressure and there
are a few of them now less than last
year
dr hayo zeeb a uh at the leibniz stupid
prevention research and epidemiology
thank you very much for talking with us
cheers